hi mystery recap here today i'm going to
explain a horror film called let her out
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
[Music]
the film starts with a young woman who
lives at the gemini motel
she's a prostitute during a busy night a
shadowy figure approaches her room
she is then attacked and raped by the
intruder she later discovers she is
pregnant and
desperate and alone takes a pair of
scissors to her unborn
killing herself in the process but the
child survives
jumping 23 years from the incident the
film shows helen
who survived her pre-birth assault from
her frightened mother
she is now a bike courier living in
toronto with her best friend
molly one day helen is tasked to deliver
goods to her friend's house named roman
that day is helen's birthday so roman
gives her a painting which he claims to
be the dark side of helen
helen immediately takes the painting
home at her motel
helen recounts to molly the story of her
mother's death
molly cares deeply about helen's
condition molly is always there to
support her as helen doesn't have any
other family
shortly molly leaves the place because
she has an appointment with her
boyfriend named ed
as she's returning from the motel helen
is struck by a car
leaving her seriously injured helen is
then taken to the hospital
she suffers a head injury and some
broken bones weeks later
helen is finally allowed to go home
molly and her friends start
throwing a small party to welcome
helen's arrival at the party
helen meets ed molly's boyfriend who
seems interested in her
when the party is going on suddenly
helen begins to experience a blackout
and lose consciousness
she wakes up in an empty parking lot
helen is confused by what happened
earlier
she immediately calls molly to ask what
happened when she was unconscious
molly explains that helen left the party
without telling her where she was going
not knowing what happened helen
immediately returns home in a state of
anxiety
at home helen starts to paint strange
pictures and because she is afraid of
roman's painting
in the end she puts it below and covers
it with a cloth
the next day helen starts her day as
usual such as exercising
eating and showering just as she
finishes taking a shower
suddenly she starts seeing a strange
figure
[Music]
then she experiences another blackout
and wakes up in front of her friends
with an injured foot
molly and others are confused there
molly explains to helen that she went
out using only a towel
for several hours helen had disappeared
and returning home
helen's foot is already bleeding helen
begins to remove the broken glass from
her feet
the next day helen and molly go to a
doctor named dr hedley to consult about
what is happening to helen
dr headley begins to ask some questions
helen explains that she is
always moving from place to place
unconsciously she was in one place
and suddenly woke up in another this has
happened frequently since the accident
furthermore she frequently sees a black
shadow after hearing her explanation
the doctor decides to perform a ct scan
on her brain
and the results will be out the next day
helen immediately returns home and goes
straight to bed
in her sleep she sees fleeting visions
of a female figure
helen wakes up to a call from dr headley
the doctor tells helen that something
strange has happened to helen's brain
hearing this ellen immediately goes to
the hospital there the doctor explains
that they discover a rare type of tumor
in her brain
it turns out that another person has
lived in her brain all this time helen's
mother
who earlier stabbed herself in an
attempt to enter pregnancy
it turns out was carrying twins one of
the fetuses was indeed killed in utero
but was subsequently absorbed into the
skull of the survivor helen
the car accident helen suffered earlier
somehow activated this long dormant twin
who is now growing at a rapid rate and
is responsible for helen's loss of
memory and erratic behavior
she now suffers from a syndrome called
vanishing twin syndrome
an actual disorder that occurs when a
twin disappears in the uterus during
pregnancy as a result of a miscarriage
of a twin
the twin is then absorbed into the body
of the surviving fetus
this results in helen having two
different personas helen and her twin
sister
then the doctor requires her to undergo
surgery to remove her twin from her
brain
however she needs to wait three days
until the surgery
later at home she sees the creepy
painting given by roman
the painting suddenly appears on the
wall she thinks that molly was the one
putting it back
but it wasn't she finally decides to
return the painting to roman
arriving at roman's house helen sees no
sign of roman
she only sees a footage on a laptop
which turns out to be helen
who was torturing roman very
sadistically the footage shows roman
begging for mercy
however unconsciously helen killed roman
helen cannot remember any of those after
walking around roman's house
she also sees broken glass and she
remembers the day she came home with an
injured foot
helen is now convinced that inside her
there are two personas
sometimes helen is in control of her
body but sometimes her twin is in
control
helen now realizes she is at war with
her own body and mind
she rushes back home and begins to tie
her hands and feet to restrain her from
going anywhere
the next day helen begins to go out for
a walk at night because she is bored at
home
however she has hallucinations and
decides to go to a nearby toilet
she starts to remove her arm cast and
opens the surgical scars on her hands
she is shocked to see another human
finger in her hand
[Music]
then she decides to leave that place
from behind
molly's boyfriend ed begins to chase
after helen
ed is very interested in the beauty of
helen therefore
he plans to rape her at that time
helen's twin begins to take control of
the body
she then points a knife at it
frightening him she immediately runs
back home after regaining consciousness
at home molly then tells helen to stop
painting weird
scary pictures but helen reveals that
she was not the one drawing the pictures
they have a debate until finally helen's
body is taken over by her twin and
starts attacking molly
[Music]
when she regains control she realizes
she could have hurt molly
eventually helen tells molly to stay
away from her
however molly refuses so helen decides
to go away from that place and stay away
from molly
on the way helen meets ed ed wants to
have revenge because helen had pointed a
knife at him before
helen begins to explain that she was
sick and that she wasn't the one doing
all that
ed doesn't listen to helen and he plans
to rape helen
at the same time her twin sister starts
to take control of helen's body and
kills it instantly
after killing ed helen regains her
consciousness and sees that ed is now
dead realizing how dangerous she has
become
helen plans to commit suicide at the
gemini motel where her mother had
committed suicide years ago
elsewhere molly begins to look back at
her photos with helen
she observes a significant difference in
her before and after pictures
she notices a shift in her personality
as well she finally concludes that
within helen's body
there are two different people and the
one who attacked her was not helen
molly immediately calls helen to find
out where she is
helen says goodbye revealing that she is
going to commit suicide at the gemini
motel
hearing this molly immediately uses her
bike and go straight to the motel
when helen has just arrived at the motel
and about to commit suicide
her twin begins to take control of her
body molly then arrives at the hotel
however it is too late her twin has
completely controlled helen's body
she immediately attacks molly
[Music]
molly tries to defend herself and
eventually she is forced to kill helen
in the final shot molly begins to walk
home remembering all her memories with
helen
and that's how the movie ends subscribe
for more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out
thank you for watching